>> EMILY (CART captioner):
Standing by.
Testing one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17,
18.
** Got quiet really fast.  I
think Dr. Hayden said it well,
it's like we're in a library.
[LAUGHTER]
** Welcome.  I'm Leanne potter.
I direct educational outreach
here.  And welcome to this very
special day.  It's special for a
number of reasons.  For
starters, it's special because
it's here at the library of
Congress, and as many of you
know the library is the largest
library
in the world.  Did you know --
I've got good notes -- did you
know that the library's
collections contain almost 164
million items in a wide variety
of formats, languages, and
subjects
.
And did you know these
collections are the single most
comprehensive accumulation of
human expression ever assembled?
And if that doesn't give you
goose bumps, then maybe the
weather does.  The collections
are broad.  They are broad in
scope and they include materials
in more than 470 different
languages, more than 35
different scripts, and many
different media formats, from
photographs to maps to drawings
to manuscripts, to sound
recordings and more.  The
collections even include books.
** I say that because sometime
we assume and not the others.
We are here in the members room.
Not your typical meeting room,
huh?  The members room in the
Thomas Jefferson building in the
Library of Congress is a good
reminder to all of us that the
like of Congress is the main
research arm of the United
States Congress.  And today is
extra special because today's
event is not the kind of event
that happens every day.  In
fact, it only happens once every
two years.  Today as you know we
are inaugurating the new
national ambassador for young
people's literature who will
serve in this position until
January of 2020.  As you
probably know, an ambassador is
someone authorized to be a
representative or messenger of
something, a great ambassador is
smart, knows what he or she is
talking about, is a champion of
an important cause, and is a
supporter and a promoter of
others others.  Hmm.  You could
almost say that the Library of
Congress is an ambassador of
sorts.  I am honored to
introduce you to Dr. Carla
Hayden, the 14th librarian of
Congress.  She earned her Ph.D.
from the university of Chicago.
She began her career as a
children's librarian.  She led
the library in Baltimore with
the president of the American
library association and is
absolutely aware of the power of
reading.  She knows the magic of
a good story and is a tremendous
ambassador for the Library of
Congress.  Dr. Hayden.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Well, good morning.  And
thank you, Leanne.  I was all
ready to sprint up and you
started doing what my mom always
loved to hear.  They never tire
that.
This is a wonderful event and
just want to say welcome.  I'm
especially happy to see the
young people from Brooklyn
middle school, the orange.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** In their wonderful shirts,
the orange sixth grade and teelt
seventh grade.  So you should
know that.  And so welcome and
we hope you come back many, many
times.  One of the many
pleasures of being librarian of
Congress is to host events like
this.  I have to say, though,
this one is very, very special.
The inauguration of our new
national ambassador for young
people's literature is
Jacqueline Woodson.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Now, I've been saying of Ms.
Woodson for a long time and in
my tenure at the library I was
very fortunate to work with
someone who was -- talk about an
ambassador, a champion
champion, a mentor for young
people's literature, Ms.  Ms.
Deborah Taylor.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** She had been an advocate, and
still is, for  respecting young
people by giving them the best
in literature.  And being the
person who also was able to
spot talent early on.  She was
the one and -- the youth
ambassador, Jin Yang, when she
said, oh, my, God, Carla, she's
going to be youth ambassador and
she'd been following him and
then Jacqueline wood Woodson in
2004 Taylor selected miracle
voice and I have my copy to the
Baltimore book and the library
purchase copies for all young
people in the city
and this was the book in 2003.
She also, and I'm going to
embarrass her a little bit, was
the person who gave Tupac
Shakur his first award.
he took her car and picked up
Tupac Shakur at home, he was 14,
to attend, and young people,
please don't laugh, there was a
beet to the book beet beat
contest.  You should see their
faces.  Yes, a library of rap
contests, right?  It was the
'80s.  We were all boogieing.
Michael Jackson, it was boogie.
And Deb tailor had a library rap
contest and she picked up young
Tupac Shakur in her car.  He was
14 and he performed his library
rap, which is now in a vault at
the library because it's in his
own hand about the library's
cool and he won the contest.
And he also was very smart
because he put a C for copyright
on it.  So Deb Taylor, thank
you, thank you, thank you,
because --
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Now, I mention Jane because
she's with us here today and
thanks to the center for the
books.  We've had five and this
will be the sixth youth
ambassador and I want to thank
John Cole for having the vision
to say this is something that
the Library of Congress should
do and also showing that respect
for our young scholars who are
coming up.  So John, we thank
you for that.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** So
we are so fortunate to have the
children's book council support
and every child a reader
foundation support.  You have
been wonderful to help the
library expand this reach and,
Gene, I have to tell you, I have
samples of graphic novels from
the folder library and from
other places that we would love
to see the Library of Congress
have.  Just saying.  So, please,
let me hand this back over to
Leanne, but thank you, thank you
all for being here.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Dr. Hayden mentioned that
Gene is here but sitting next to
her is one of our impar doors.
I think they ought to stand up,
please.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** I think she's within -- I
think she's marvelous.  Thank
you, Dr. Hayden.  It is my
pleasure to welcome Carl lenders
up here to the podium, director
of the child's book council and
of every child a reader.  He is
busy.  He oversees the
development and expansion of
both organizations programming
and that programming includes a
few things you probably heard
before.  How about children's
book week?
And the children's choice book
awards as well as the national
ambassador for young people's
literature.  Carl, come on up.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** I have a B in psychology.  I
was fit to work in a bookstore,
that was my education, but thank
you all.  Okay, who likes magic?
Good answer.  Give me three or
four minutes to say some it's
and I have a magic trick.  Shana
's going oh, no.  Thank you to
all the young people here.
Brooklyn middle school, school
librarian.  Thank you very much
for being here.  The room is
full of a lot of other young
people.  Adults whoever young at
heart, spirit, and we are that
way every day because we read,
write, illustrate, publish, and
share books with children and
teens every day and that keeps
us young at heart and that's a
joyful thing.  We say we go to
work.  We love going to work.
It is work, but it's a joy every
day to do our work to bring
books to young people everywhere
.  I want to take a moment,
minute and a half or so or two
or three to deal with the
hundreds of thousands of people
every day who bring books to
readers everywhere.  Some of us
here today and watching on live
stream, not too nervous, book
publishers who discovered
talented writers print their
works and get them to readers.
There's a lot more than that but
I only have five minutes.  The
book publishers also support the
work of children's book council
and every child a reader,
including the ambassador
program.  Thank you all here
today.  Thank you for the board
members who made it and thank
you for all the council members
watching at work.  Some of us
here today are librarians, those
amazing people in every town and
city in America.  I'm a library
kid from a small town.  Went
there every day bringing books
to kids and adults everywhere.
A special thanks to the super
hero librarians.  Dr. Hayden,
Library of Congress, and injury
staff, Leanne, Karen, Gail,
Wendy, all a joy.  Thank you
very much.  Scarlet from Vermont
, thank you for coming down.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** She was on our selection
committee which I'll come back
to in just a moment.  Some of us
here are independent book
sellers for, those passionate
people who with librarians in a
community they're the roots, in
touch with everybody in America
more than all of us can ever be,
hundredses of thousands of book
settlers who read the books
ahead of time and reach the
heart and soul through America.
We would not have the diverse
spirit, talent, literature
without independent book sellers
and librarians.  We have an
independent book seller, Deandra
Beard, thank you for  coming.
Thanks for being here, being on
the call with us.  It's
wonderful.  This one's
underlined because you went to
public school.  To the teachers
here today and everywhere I
consider your professions as
important in the health and
well-being of our kids and to us
as much as doctors and nurses.
Public school teachers rock.
[ APPLAUSE ]
So do college teachers.  We have
two of them here.  Sarah, thank
you for coming in and.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** And Susanna Richards who is a
children's art illustration guru
, historian, friend
of us in general and good idea
person.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** To the media here today thank
you for protecting the free flow
of information every day.
Without you we're in trouble.
And who review books, very
important.  To others here at
home the importance of getting
books and stories to those in
need every day from first book
to workshop, library movement
which is awesome from open books
to the PTA and more
organizations and charities and
places, ALA, ABC, it's an
acronym world but you all every
day getting books to people who
need books which is important.
I'm here on behalf of my small
but passionate wonderful team
back in New York, Lauda, Scffit,
Ryan Mepa and Kelly graham.  I
know you haven't got water in
the office that you're hugged
around the coffee machine.  It's
rough.  And for two people here,
Walter bolten and if he will
Felicity who made all the
interviews happen.  And for
Jacqueline given the interview
it's so wonderful.  It's
stressful.  Thank you for doing
that.  We got major coverage
across the country.  I think
we're talking about 100
million-dollar media impression
about books, reading, love of
books, it was wonderful.  And
Shanena, my director of program
supportership.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** You're here in two years.
She does so much and I cannot
thank you enough.
To the magic makers, the writers
, illustrators everywhere who
create the word and future
stories that delight us every
day, and, yes, talking back to
the young at heart thing.  John
Testa, your books make me smile.
Jin  Yang, thank you Smalley lin
Woodson, what a gift to the
world you are.  You teach us,
make us wiser, better,  stronger
.
Love of books and art
illustration and highlight last
year was your selection of
ambassador.  We're happy for you
and the young people you'll
reach with your message, energy,
and power of storytelling.
Thank you all of you in the book
world.  You make a difference
every day.  We'll see you again
until book week, the first week
in May, national festival of
book.  Jackie's on the road
talking, selling her books,
doing her thing
.  All right.  Time for a magic
act.  I am going to disappear
back to my seat.
[LAUGHTER]
** And let the real magic makers
take the stage.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Thank you, Carl.  Very nice.
It is my pleasure to be reminded
that I'm shorter than Carl.  It
is my pleasure to welcome Jin
Yang to this stage.  I'm going
to tell you about him just in
case you didn't know.  For the
past two year Jin has served as
the fifth ambassador for young
people's literature.  He was
born and raised in California
and is the son of Chinese
immigrants.  Has been drawing
comics since the fifth grade.
In 2006 his book, American born
Chinese was published and became
the first graphic novel to be
nominated for a national book
award.  And it was the first to
win the American Library
Association's prince award.  In
2013 his two volume graphic
novel about the boxer rebellion
was nominated as well for a
narnl book award and won the
L.A. Times book prize.  In
addition -- and I could go on,
but -- in addition to cartooning
he is also a  teacher.  He is
currently teaching creative
writing and has been a
tremendous national ambassador.
His platform, reading without
walls has challenged all of us
to stretch our reading habits in
very important ways.  Jin.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Good morning, everyone.  I am
so excited to be here.  Two
years ago in this same building
in a different room, but same
building, I got the fanciest
thing that I own.  I got the
national ambassador for young
people's literature
medal and the last two years
have been among the most amazing
of my life.  I want to thank Dr.
Hayden, Carl, and Shayna and
everyone else for your support.
I want to especially thank the
librarians and teachers and book
sellers that have made these
past two years so magical.  Last
two years I've gone around the
country to talk to young people
from all different communities
in America.  What I've
discovered is that kids love
books.  Despite what what some
adults might lead to you think,
kids still love books.  And they
love books for the same reason
we all love books.  It's because
stories help us make sense of
our lives, of the world.  That's
why I am so excited to be here
today, because today we all in
this room get to witness one of
the greatest story tellers of
our time receive the
martial ambassador for young
people medal.  Jackie Woodson is
one of my heroes.  She is a
person that I deeply admire.  I
admire her not just as a writer
but also as a human being.  I
believe that her ambassadorship
is simply going to be an
extension of the work she's
already doing.  If you have had
the pleasure of reading one of
Jackie's books, if you had the
pleasure of sitting in on one of
her speeches, you know that
words, whether they're spoken
into a microphone
or written on a page, she
teaches about the world, helps
us make sense of life and the
world.  Her words bring us hope,
bring about change.  Like I
said, she's one of my heroes.
And if she isn't one of yours
yet, give her a few minutes.
Wait until she gets up here.
She'll be one of yours too.
Thank you all so much for being
here.  I know you all are just
as excitedderred as me to
celebrate ambassador Jacqueline
Woodson.  Thank you so much.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Thank you.  And thank you for
your last two years.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** I asked Jin to stay here with
me.  Now I'm going to ask Dr. Ha
why,den to join us.  We're going
to start telling you really cool
things about Jackie.
Jacqueline Woodson is the author
of more than two dozen award
winning books for young adults,
middle graders, and children.
Her books address important
topics, such as  bullying and
kindness, incarceration,
identity, mixed race experiences
and much more.  Among her many
accolades, she is a four-time Ne
wberry medal winner, and a
two time Heretta scolt Scott
king recipient.
** In 2014 she received the
national book award for her New
York Times best selling memoirs
brown girl dreaming.  You all
read this book?  It's an amazing
book.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Which was also a recipient of
the new Barry, NAACP image I
award and cyber honor.  In 2014
Jacqueline Woodson was named the
young people's poet laureate by
the poetry foundation and some
of her other books include the
other side, each kindness,
coming on home soon, feathers,
show  way, actor Tupac
and foster and miracle boys.
** She is also the recipient of
the Margaret Alexander Edwards
award for lifetime achievement
for her contributions to young
adult literature.  The winner of
the Jane Adams children book
award and was the 2013 United
States nomny for the Hans
Christian Anderson award.
Penguin young readers will
celebrate the 20th anniversary
of her if you came  softly with
a special edition of the adored
story of star crossed love
between a black teenage boy and
his Jewish classmate.
** And later this year the dream
of America, a middle grade novel
written by Woodson and the day
you begin, a picture book also
written by Woodson and
illustrated by Ralph yellow pes
will be published.  But today --
should we get a drum in here (
drumming) she officially becomes
the sixth national ambassador
for young people's literature.
Dr. Hayden is going to make it
official as soon as Jackie gets
up here and places a medallion
around her neck.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Our photographers right there
waiting for a picture and then
I'm stepping out of it.
All right.  Excellent.  Dr.
Hayden and Jacqueline are going
to have a conversation.  With
ten minutes into the
conversation Jacqueline is going
to come up here and make some
remarks especially for all of us
and then we'll open it up for
questions from the audience
starting with our students from
Brooklyn middle school.  Thanks.
** Well, this is just an honor
for all of us, and a special
pleasure.
** Yay.
** Special, special pleasure.
Yes, my copy.  My copy.  Just
saying.  But you have been such
an inspiration.
** so have you, Dr. Hayden.
Thank you.
** Now, I remember my favorite
book was called bright April and
it was the first time that I
could see myself in a book.
Little girl, she was brown, had
pigtail, all of that.  And I you
talk about not seeing yourself
reflected and that's why miracle
voice was one of the things that
wow, what's that mean to see
yourself.
** Well, I think it's so
important looking back on the
work of Dr. bishop who talked
about the importance of young
people having both mirrors and
windows.  So they have books
where they can look in and see a
brown girl or a young Latin boy
or an Asian girl and see some
part of their identity in the
book and that's the mirror and
it makes them aware of their
presence in a bigger world.  And
I think we also talk about books
having windows.  So you see into
other worlds and for me as a
young person growing up I had
many, many windows into white
worlds and very few books where
young kids of color were
reflected on the pages, until I
think one of the earliest books
I remember reading was Virginia
Hamilton's -- oh, what's --
Zeally, about two kids and they
were going down south and there
was so much of me on the page.
Another one was Mildred's role
thunder hear my cry.  Opened to
see a reflection in myself in
Cassie and suddenly realized
that
there I was on the page and that
I could be on the page.  Not
only could I be on the page but
I could be -- I could grow up to
be a woman of color who wrote
because here was am I dread
tailor, Virginia Hamilton, women
of color telling stories.  I
think it's -- legitimizes us
that we don't realize our
absence until we see that
presence on a page.
** You mentioned wanting to
write.  How young were you when
you said I like this writing?
Reading but writing.  I want to
do that?
** I've known I wanted to write
since I was seven.  I remember
as a young person loving the
physical act of writing, of
holding a pencil and words made
sentences and sentences made
paragraphs and that writing was
organic.  All you needed was
that pencil and paper and
imagination and the rest was
there.  You didn't need any
expensive paraphernalia to be
able to create art.
** Wow.  Turning to the -- in
terms of pair nailra and things
like that because there are so
many distractions and things so
people have said read something
disappearing and what's going on
with young people.  What do you
--
** I don't think --  I think we
see fewer books sometimes with
you I don't think people are not
reading.  I think sometimes we
have to wrestle them and get
their paraphernalia
out of their hand and remind
them of the glory of reading but
I think as Jin said, young
people love story and they love
being engaged that way and there
are many ways in which we read.
So I think even though we're not
always seeing them with a book
in their hand, they have one in
their ear.  Sometimes they're
reading on the tablet, sometimes
someone is telling a story,
sometimes they're creating a
story in their head some way.
So I think it's definitely got
more challenging but we're a
country that has always had to
shift.  So we figure out ways of
engaging people where they are
and if they are in a world where
there's a lot of technology then
what are we going to do to shift
them toward reading, how do we
get them to shift from that
technology where they're
engaging with narrative.
** Poetry as another way, a
gateway into that.  Now, when
did you start with poetry as
another extension of --
** You know, I didn't -- I was
very afraid of poetry when I was
a kid.  I always thought it was
just kind of this secret code
that I wasn't meant to
understand and it wasn't until
-- I remember hearing an album,
my mom was playing this album
and it was Giovani.  It was
spoken word and I was like what
is that.  My sister was that's
Nicky, that's poetry.  And I'm
like no it's not.  I understand
that.  That's not poetry.  And
then later on
Lagston Hughes and Claude Mc KAY
unlocked it so that I could
begin to understand other poets
the more kind of incom
incomprehensible, but poetry I
learned to do the work of
deconstructing poetry because I
had the gateway from Langston
Hughes and Nicky  Giovanni,
Gyendolynn Brooks and so many of
the writers that helped me
figure that out.
** I remember my grandmother,
Paul Lawrence done Dunbar and
how could you do the dialect.
She said I know.  I can do  it.
** Had a great -- yeah, got to
love him.
** Now, Tupac we mentioned and
rap is another way.
** He was an amazing poet.  I
mean, Tupac when you look at the
rose that grew from concrete and
just he was not only a poet; he
was an activist.  And I think
that's what was so phenomenal
about him as so many of the
young people who were wrapping,
they were telling stories, they
were telling history.  They were
breaking down where we are in
the moment and they were doing
it in a way going back to
shifting where young minds could
understand what they were trying
to say.  And they were asking
big questions and I think that's
what all good literature does is
ask questions of the reader of
the listener about the moment
they're in.
** Speaking of the moment, your
platform, reading equals hope
and change for your time, how do
you see that evolving?  Because
this is an interesting time to
be an ambassador, to work with
young people, to ask questions,
to answer questions.
** So reading equals hope times
change is a platform that I came
up with, that we came up with
that speaks to the fact that
reading does allow -- we go into
a book because we're hopeful for
something.  We're hopeful for a
good  story, hopeful to meet
some mirrors on the page.  We're
hopeful for great
characterization.  And when we
come out of a book, we're
different.  And that difference
is because we have met the
writer halfway.  I'm going to
talk about this in my very short
talk after this.  I think that
books can change us, help us
begin to have the bigger
conversations.  They can help us
see the world and identities and
ideas that we never thought
about before until they have
been brought to the page and we
met them on the page.  So I
think we come out of a book
different than we were when we
went in it.
** Now, one of the questions I
had here that you have been
aplawrded and criticized for
tackling tough issues.  Getting
back to respecting young people
that they can handle discussion
about tough issues.  They're
looking to books sometimes to
help them through it, foster
care, incarceration, and why is
that important that we have it.
** I think the first thing is
I'm not trying to hear the
haters.  You know what I'm
saying?  From the beginning of
time people who have had -- who
have tried to create change have
been blasted against, right?
And I think it's because people
are afraid.  When we look at the
issue of mass incarceration in
our country, I think it's a sin
not to speak to it and not to
let the young people who have --
who know -- who have people in
their families, in their lives,
incarcerated let them know
they're not alone on that
journey and that there is
nothing wrong with their family
makeup and there is nothing --
you know, when I wrote visiting
day is because I had grown up
with my uncle in prison.  It was
this kind of thing we weren't
supposed to talk about.  And I
never understood where the shame
came from and looking at it now
again going back to mass
incarceration, how can we try to
hide something so visible in our
society.  And if we don't talk
about it we can't begin to
change it.  We can just kind of
make believe it doesn't exist.
So I think any writer who's
going to try to have harder
conversations is going to get
criticized.  I remember writeing
where an African-American boy
gets killed by cops in a case of
mistaken identity, people -- I
remember people saying this
would never happen.  And this
was 20 years ago and at some
point you kind of question your
own reality because you think,
oh, maybe this doesn't happen
but you know it does and that
kind of gas liting can happen
when you don't have the proof of
books and experiences in the
world so that you can go to that
book and go, yeah, I'm not alone
in this.  I was right in
thinking about that because
someone else is thinking this
too.
** And young people can see it
and discuss it and they can
handle it.
** Mm-hmm.
** I think they can.
Now, you also said brilliance is
passion recognized.  This is a
wonderful phrase.  In
termination of encouraging young
readers and authors and poets,
that they see that.
** They know -- I think it was
so important.  I was talking to
my book land friends and we were
talking about their talents and
their plans for going -- what
they do.  It is, I think, that
sometimes people think there's
just one way to be brilliant.
Maybe only academic brilliance
or -- but I think I think our
brilliance is our passion
recognized and celebrated, right
?  I know that I'm kind of a
good writer and it's nice
because it's also what I love to
do.  And I think because I love
to do it I want to do it the
best that I possibly can.  I
remember having a teacher say
when you choose a career, choose
something you love doing because
you're going to be doing it for
the rest of your life and I
think that those words stayed
with me because I thought
hopefully I would live a long
life and the idea of waking up
every day and being unhappy with
the work you're doing was
heartbreaking to me.  So I honed
the thing that I felt was my
brilliance and worked at it
until it became the thing I
wanted it to be in the world,
the stories I wanted to tell and
I think everyone has that thing
that they're really good at that
they really love doing and our
work as adults is to not kill
that fire.  Your work as young
people is to not let that fire
get murdered.  And then we get
to see all of that brimmans in
the world in a way that
transforms it and transforms us.
** Can writing help with that?
You said look through moments in
time into a more hopeful place
about writing or expressing it,
using it along the way.
** I think writing can help with
everything (chuckles).  I think
writing is the bomb.  I talk
about writing because I have
questions and I do think that
there is a way when we can sit
and begin to figure out who we
are and who we're becoming and
what the questions are we have
through writing and reading.  I
believe deeply, deeply and I
love when young people want to
be writers because I know here
because of Nicky Giovanni,
Langston Hughes, gend Lynn
brooks.  I would not be here if
they were not here.  I feel the
young people are here because of
us, because of, you know, Gene
and John and Catherine and me
and let that circle be unbroken.
Let people keep coming and
telling their stories because
y'all must have some amazing
stories to tell about this
moment in time.
** I see you're nodding.  Do we
have time for a few remarks?
** Yes.
** And I'm going to exit.
** Thanks, Dr. Hayden.  I'm not
going to be long because I am so
much more interested in your
questions.  Maybe I'll answer a
few of them but I love when
young people ask me questions.
But I was told I needed to say
something about becoming
ambassador.
Is it still morning because I
start with saying good morning.
Okay.  Oh, I have a -- people
who are live  streaming is my
sound okay?  I'm good?  I could
keep using this?  I could use
both of them.  Thank you.
So it's an amazing honor to
stand before you in the Library
of Congress this morning.  It's
also an honor to be living in
this time to bear witness to our
countries ' beautiful and
complicated history and its
immense possibility.  Because I
do believe we're living in a
time of great, great, great
possibility
.
What an honor to follow the
footsteps of groundbreaking
ambassadors that came before me,
Jin Yang, not only my absolute
hero which makes me think he
read my speech because he called
me his hero.
[LAUGHTER]
** But he's also a hero to both
my children and to many children
.  Camillo who was the
inspiration for us naming our
cat Fred, who never fails to
make me laugh or choke up with
each book she writes.  Catherine
Patterson, one of the  kindest
people I know.  Walter Myers who
came into this world and left it
with his untimely passing filled
with a body of work that changed
consciousness of so many young
men and boys of color and so
many others as well.
I miss  Walter.  Walter, who
during his advertisement as
national ambassador time as
national ambassador tirelessly
spoke to those who had not
thought about themselves as part
of the bigger world or deeper
narrative.  Beloved pioneer,
John Chesta, neighbor, friend,
and awesome writer sitting among
us this morning.  I would not be
here without y'all.
First and foremost I want to
thank the people who have worked
beyond hard to bring me to this
moment, the most fabulous
Library of Congress and Dr.
Carla Hayden, my sister from
another mother and hisry maker.
My dear friend Debbie tailor and
all of my people at Pratt
library.  It was here doing a
reading from my first novel last
summer that I rediscovered the
breadth and depth of libraries
.  Reading, conversations,
children's programs, program for
young mothers, adult literacy
classes, passport renewals,
puppet making, all of it was, is
happening at the libraries.  At
Pratt and nationwide.  As I
began to travel I saw in every
single state the enormitity of
what libraries both large and
small had to offer anyone who
stepped through their doors.  I
rediscovered libraries aren't
just for some people, they're
for all people.
I like to thank the children's
book council, every child a
reader and the commit that chose
me to succeed Jin, Deandra,
Sarah, Earl, Travis, Dara, and
Ellen and of course Jin.  I love
your faith in me and I'm
grateful, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
** For it.
I wouldn't be standing here
without my penguin family, my
longstanding editor Nancy
Paulson, Jen, Felicia, Cecelia
and the rest of the crew.  A
writer writers in solitude and
then steps outside of the
solitude to get the help they
need to shape their work into
something that the rest of the
world can understand.
When I wrote brown girl dreaming
there were 31 rewrites before it
became the book so many of y'all
have read and then some tweaks
between the first and second
edition.  So if you have that
first edition, hold on.
My eyes in the world are my own
eyes and the eyes of those who I
trust deeply.  Nancy, thank you
for being my second set of eyes
in the world.  I am thankful too
to my amazing family, my partner
Juliette, our children, Toshi,
Jackson, and Laroi, all my
sisters from other mothers, Jane
Sessing and the ones who
couldn't be with us as well.
There are a lot of them.  Y'all
would be sitting here forever.
[LAUGHTER]
** And I want to thank those who
have been with me on this
journey from it feels like the
moment it began, including Katy
Horning, Dr. Radeen intish shop,
Dean Snyder.  In this room with
us this morning are those who
guide us now as ancestor
, Virginia Hamilton, my mom and
grandmother.  Let us each take a
moment and remember someone who
has left this place for the next
one, who continues from that
place to walk with us.  In the
afternoon can American tradition
there is a calling of names.  We
call our ancestors back into the
room where we acknowledge that
because of them, we are.  Let us
take a moment and remember
friends, loved ones, relives,
anyone we can think of, writers
who have left us and who remain
important and call out their
names.
** (Away from microphone).
** Thank you.  Your world is as
big as you make it.  I know for
I used to abide in the
narrowestnest in the corner, my
wings pressing close to my side,
but you cited a distant horizon
with the guideline and circled
the sea and I throbbed with a
burning desire to travel this
immensesty.  I battered the
Cordons around me and craideld
my wingsz on the breeze, then
sorried with the utter most
reaches -- I'm sorry, and
sorried to the other most
reaches with raptture, with
power, with ease.  I wish I had
written that poem, but I didn't.
Tfers written by Georgia Douglas
Johnson who for more than 40
years hosted a salon right here
in D.C. on Smith street
southwest for those of you who
don't know a salon is basically
a gathering where you come eat
food, drink good wine and
organic milk, young people.
[LAUGHTER]
, read your work and the work of
others, maybe get a sypher going
and share ideas about the world.
Through the sharing of these
ideas you begin to change your
own way of thinking and the way
others think.  But it starts
with gathering.  Through
Douglas' salon came some of the
most influential writers of the
Renaissance, from Angelina Wells
Gremky, Gene Tumer, poets
at the end of my tenure -- I
will know how to pronounce the
word, and we will all know them.
Reading equals hope times change
.  When Georgia Douglas Johnson
began those writes salons no one
knew that the Harlem Renaissance
would take a very important
place in history.  No one knew
that one day Mildred tailor
would write roll of thunder,
hear my cry, that Jin Yang would
write American born Chinese,
that same Monday J. or tease
would write people shall
continue or the absolute
Sherman
Alexii.  The people in Douglas'
salon walked into that room with
the books they were writing or
reads.  They walked into that
salon with hope.  They read,
they talked, they laughed, drank
beer, wine, and milk, they sang
and changed the world because of
them I am.  Because of them we
are all gathered here.
Yesterday my family and I spent
the day at the American museum
of African-American history and
culture again right here in D.C.
It took over 100 years to make
that museum a reality.  First it
was dreams, then it was built,
then people opened their
trungses and suitcases and books
and pulled history from
African-Americans in this
country from the crevices into
which that history was
delicately and lovingly packed
away.  They knew a time would
come when that history would
need a home.  Now is the time.
As national ambassador my hope
is to begin a conversation our
country is hungry but oftentimes
afraid to have.  Some days this
place feels like a country
divided, a country in despair, a
country hungry for a way out of
no way.  What the books will
continue to show us is there is
magic in this moment we're
living in now.  There is so much
possibility.  To the young
people gathered today, that
power to create change is in
your hearts and heads and hands.
I am often asked about my
writing.  When you write this
book or that book what were you
trying to teach?
.  I write to learn.  I write
because I have so many questions
that I have to answer and the
only way I can answer is by
putting pen to paper.  The only
way I can find hope I'm looking
for in a particular moment is to
put that hope on the page and
when I'm done like many writers
my hope has been that the reader
will meet me halfway.  Bring
their own ideas and experiences
and hope to the narrative I've
created.  My hope for the next
two years is we come together in
many rooms to talk, that we meet
the authors halfway and talk
about what our hopes are for the
future, our equations, plans for
change, that we hold salons and
classrooms and libraries and
book stores and living rooms
around kitchen tables, in
playgrounds, at hair salons and
barber shops, that we find the
books that tell the stories we
need to hear and use those
stories to write the next
chapter in this country's
history.  We remember a time
when people were not allowed to
learn to read because reading
led to freedom.  It's a lot of
things to be -- it's a lot of
things in this room at this
podium in front of all of you in
this moment in time.  It's scary
, thrilling, mind blowing,
imagining the unimagineable.
The writer activist Audrey Lord
said we can sit in our corners
mute and we will still be no
less afraid.  I believe that
reading equals  hope, hope times
change.  I believe that me plus
you equals a conversation.  I
believe that hope minus fear
equals change.  I believe that
listening plus hearing minus
judgment equals friendship.
These are just a few of my
equations in the next two years
I'm eager to gather and hear
yours.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** You did good.
** Thank you.
** Outstanding.  Well, now it's
time for some questions and my
audiovisual team has told me
there are two mics that we can
float around the room if you've
got one in your hand would you
let me see it?  Awesome.
Perfect.  So how about one of
you come over to this side and
one stay on that side.  If you
guys could raise your hands when
you've got a question, we'll
make sure that you get the mic.
The reason we need to make sure
you use the mic is so that our
audience that's watching the
live stream and our recording
can hear your question, okay?
** And if you could say your
name when you ask the question,
that would be so helpful.
** My name is Christian
Strickland.
** Hi, Christian.
** what do you plan to do after
your term is over?
[LAUGHTER]
** Thanks, Christian.
Oh, man.  I think it's going to
go so fast.  I plan to rest.  I
don't plan to stop writing
because I talk about how much I
love writing.  I plan to be
right here all willing putting
this medal on the next
ambassador.
** My name is Louis seaia
Brisbane.  What do you plan to
do while you're ambassador?
** I plan to do a lot around
trying to get people to gather.
I don't -- one thing you have to
do as ambassador is travel
around the country.
Legitimately only have to travel
five times, right?  That was one
of the promises of being
ambassador
.  I think there are all kinds
of ways together.  I think we
can Skype.  I think people can
come to book festivals.  I think
we can gather in classrooms.  I
plan to help kind of get the
conversation going from wherever
I am.  I hope to meet a lot of
people, travel to a lote of
juvenile detention centers and
group homes and places like that
to meet people who might not
have otherwise met authors.  My
family's going to Mississippi in
April so I'm planning to go to
some of the play schools and
libraries in rural Mississippi
while I'm there and really just
begin having a conversation that
I hope will become a very
nationwide conversation
.
** My name is Cameron Jackson
and I was wondering do you guys
have anybody in mind to be the
next ambassador?
** Cameron's already ready to
sack me.  He's like do you have
someone in mind for the next
impairs door?   Cameron, I'm
sure they'll take your request.
** High hi,
hi, my name is Dionne.  How old
were you when you published your
first book.
** That was published when I was
in my early 20s.  It took me
about four years to write that
book because I didn't know what
I was doing.  So unlike many
years it took me to do brown
girlt dreaming, by it was
finally published in my early
20s:  There was a book that was
published before that that was
really bhadly written by me and
really badly illustrated by
Floyd Cooper and that book is
not in existence anymore.
Sometimes a librarian will pull
it out and say I got that book
but last time
.
** My name is Destiny Perry.
Out of all books that you have
read and the characters you have
met in those books, what book or
character is most like you.
** That's such a great question.
Oh my goodness.  It's so funny
because I feel the person that
comes to mind that first said
that's me was Cathy Logan and
roll of thunder, hear my cry.  I
feel like also Franny and daddy
was a return and Francis Nolan
and a tree grows in Brooklyn,
any time there was a girl around
the age I was when I was reading
and who had something so for me
a tree grows in Brooklyn the
mirror was Brooklyn because
that's where I live.  Everything
Brooklyn about that book I was
like I know this even though it
took place probably 40 years
before I began reading it, but I
did and still do find myself in
so many characters and they
don't have to be the same --
preferred gender, right?  I
found myself in characters like
ghost, Jason Reynold's book.  I
read that book and I was like
yeah I was a runner.  I could
probably beet him but -- so
really so were a lot of
characters.
** My name is joes lin Rose and
my question is have you ever
thought about having another
career instead of writing?
** I don't know if anyone heard
the question, have I thought of
having another career besides
being a writer.   No, I don't
think so.  I would probably want
to be a singer.  Just kidding.
My family's laughing because
they've heard  me.
Yeah, no.
** My name isadere.  Did
you have a place to go where you
write a story.
** Once my family leaves the
house I'm usually writing at the
kitchen table, but I tend to --
I like writing downstairs in my
office because it's quietest.
Every time I write I put
headphones on.  So it helps me
drown out the rest of the world.
So even though I don't have to
physically leave a place, I do
have to kind of cover up my ears
so that noise isn't coming in.
But I have been able to write on
sub waist.  ways, cafes,
libraries, as long as I have my
earphones on.  Because I don't
want to hear other people's
conversations.
** My name is Shakara.  Did you
ever expect to be the ambassador
for national young people's lit
tier?
** Nope.
[LAUGHTER]
**
My name is Louie Redmond.  My
question is:  Did you have any
challenges becoming an author
and how did you overcome them?
** You know, it's a good
question.  I always quote
Catherine Patterson who says the
main role of writing is  BIC,
but in care.  The older I got
there are more and more things
as Dr. Hayden and I were talking
about, there are more things
that distract you from writing
and so as a young person I
didn't know writers.  I didn't
know that someone -- it wasn't
like now where you could
actually need a writer and hear
them talk or go online and see
them talk or even look at the
back of the book and see their
photo and know stuff about them.
It was a very different time.
Writers seemed really far away
and something unattainable,
something you couldn't do.  For
some reason I knew I always
wanted to do it and I wasn't
sure how I was going to.  I
think the first huge challenge
for me was faith, right?
Believing that I could write
these stories that might some
day get published.  But in the
process of writing the sphrees I
realized that writing made me
happy.  Even if they didn't one
day get published I loved
writing them.  And then the big
challenge was finishing stories
and then rewriting stories.
Because you write something that
you think is  done, right,
Jackson, and then you realize up
to rewrite it and rewrite it.
That was a challenge.  Then once
realizing how rewriting made it
a better story.  But I think
there are always going to be
challenges and the question is
when you get to the challenge
what you do with it because
there's always going to be the
book that falls apart and you
could either just stop writing
and start a new book which is
going to fall apart and you stop
writing that one and start a new
book which is going to fall
apart or you can push through
when it's falling apart and get
to the end of it.  I ask my
fellow office everything we
write falls apart.  That's when
we know the real work is about
to get started.
** My name is lorn and my
question is how do you come up
with the topics for your book?
** So there's a saying if you
survive kindergarten you have
enough to write about for the
rest of your life and I think
it's true.  I think so many
things happen to us every day
and I'm sure John and Jin will
tell you this, it's hard to not
write.  It's hard not to find
material.  So, you  know,
thoughts I have, conversations I
have, sometimes things I read,
sometimes other books inspire me
.  Sometimes questions I -- a
lot of times it's the questions
I have that I'm trying to figure
out.  When I wrote the book
feathers that was actually
inspired by a story called a
selfish giant by Oscar Wild and
the book was originally called
the Jesus boy because that's
what I called the main character
in the selfish giant.  It was
inspired by something I first
read in the third grade.  So I
think that's where the whole --
the longer you live the more
stories you have to write.
** Is there a specific theme --
** What's your name?
** Oh, my name is justice.
Is there a specific theme or
topic in all of your books or
are they like different in each
one?
** They're pretty different.  I
don't write series because I get
bored after like the second
book.  I've's spider to do it
and then I either kill the
characters off or have them move
away or let they want have a
hatchly happily ever after.  I
write realistic fiction.  That's
the genre.  I write it both in
verse and narrative.  But
usually my characters are
different.  I've written a trill
lodgegy.  I've written books
that have equals
sequels but that's about as long
as I can get.
** I'm Dionne and my question is
out of all the books that you've
written 1:00 is your personal
favorite?
** I'm sure again my fellow
ambassadors will say the same
thing.  I like them for
different reasons.  I don't have
-- do y'all have favorites?
When you're writing it it's the
experience you're having with a
book.  Sometimes if the book is
really old you get tired of it.
I have books I like less than
other books but I don't have a
favorite yet.
** Your questions have been
terrific.
You need a mic.  It's coming.
There you go.
** Carl.  When you first started
writing, did you show it to a
friend?  You seem preallot
confident and you knew your book
was good but what was your first
validation?  My point being one
of these people from brook rine
starts writing, would you tell
them just go ahead or show it to
a friend?
** I would say the question is
who are you writing to?  I think
you show it to people you trust
because there are two kinds of
criticism, right?  24R's
constructive criticism that
makes people running back to
your work and there's
deconstructive criticism, which
makes you want to throw it away.
You want to show it to the
people who are going to say, you
know, here's all the things I
love about this book and here
are some of the questions I
might have.  Because that's
helpful and makes you want to go
back to it but if someone says,
you know, I don't know, this
sucks or you should never write
again, that speaks to their
criticism.  I don't even know
why you're writing that.  But
one thing I do is I like -- I
always think it's really
important when you have
something new and you say to
them ask me three questions.
What three questions do you
have?  Tell me something
positive, oh, I love that
character, I wonder why he
decided to do this.  I wonder
what's going to happen to him
next and that gets you excited
and makes you want to write the
next draft or add to it.  So
questions, not destructive
criticism.
** All right.  I think we're
going to wrap things up.  That
was -- just stay right there for
a minute.  Really, stiewbs from
Brooklyn middle school, thanks
so much.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** Can I just say one thing?
** Yeah.
** So I am sorry, I just wanted
to give a plug of the book
change the narratives of
literature and I want to thank
them for being in the room even
though they're not in the room.
** Well, I am confident that our
young people's ambassador -- our
ambassador for young people's
literature is well on her way to
making lots of friends in the
next couple of years and getting
all of us to think about very
thoughtfully about reading and
writing and I really can't say
enough.  This has been a
terrific conversation this
morning and really so glad that
all of you have been here.  I
have a couple more thank yous I
want to extend.  I want to make
sure that my colleagues, Karen
Jaffe why and Sasha and Monica
Valentine get a big high-five.
[ APPLAUSE ]
, as well as all of the
volunteers from our young
readers center, our molted tie
media team, library photographer
Shawn and our special events
person Clay who I don't see but
events like this at the library
don't happen magically.  They
happen when people come together
and make things happen.  We are
briesed at the library to have
an amazing team of people who
pull together events like this.
Thank you to all of my
colleagues for making today work
.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I want to make sure as we leave
we ask the kids to go first.
I'd like you guys to kind of
come around this way.  You can
give Jackie a high-five as you
walk by.  Our colleagues have a
special gift for you from
penguin.  They are signed copies
of one of Jackie's book.  If you
haven't read it yet I bet you
will tonight.  Awesome.
Congratulations again, Jackie.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We're off to a great year.
[ APPLAUSE ]
** All right, kids, you can get
started.  Come this way and
thank you all for joining us.